we're going to begin in Virginia
everybody's talking about this we're the
top three officials in that state
government are now all caught up in
separate scandals three different ones
Attorney General Mark herring admitted
yesterday he did wear blackface to a
college costume party back in 1980
one state lawmaker says when when airing
when herring rather apologized at a
meeting several people were crying a few
days ago herring called for Virginia
Governor Ralph Northam to resign after a
yearbook photo showing a man in
blackface
we're also learning more about an
allegation of sexual misconduct against
Virginia lieutenant governor Justin
Fairfax which he denies yet O'Keefe is
at the Capitol building in Richmond heed
good morning good morning bianna just a
couple hours after the Attorney General
admitted that he had once posed in
blackface the professor accusing the
lieutenant governor of sexual assault
went public with her allegations and
then last night the editorial board at
the Washington Post which here in
Virginia is considered an influential
local newspaper called on governor Ralph
Northam to step down it's fair to say
nobody has ever seen anything quite like
this we need to help hold everybody to
the same standard Virginians are really
he should be held accountable we're
screwed and we need to replace them and
lawmakers at the State Capitol are in
shock after Attorney General Mark
herring revealed he painted his face
black while in college in 1980 herring
said in a statement Wednesday he joined
friends in dressing like rappers we
listened to at the time putting on wigs
and brown makeup to perform a song at a
party on Saturday he said it is no
longer possible for governor Northam to
lead the Commonwealth after a racist
photo including a man in blackface
was discovered on North American School
yearbook page the latest revelation
rocked Virginia Democrats including
those in Washington's
Friday 10 hours has been further
complicating things for Democrats the
first in line to replace Northam
Lieutenant Governor Justin Fairfax faces
a sexual assault allegation his accuser
Vanessa Tyson released a statement
saying at the 2004 Democratic convention
in Boston consensual kissing quickly
turned into a sexual assault
when Fairfax forced her to perform oral
sex on him Fairfax has denied her
allegation and said in a statement
reading dr. Tyson's account is painful I
have never done anything like what she
suggests out we're at a point where no
one seems to have clean hands Jeff
Shapiro has covered Virginia politics
for nearly 40 years
the political aftershocks of all this
Virginia has an election every year this
year's a particularly consequential one
in that the legislature is up for grabs
that's right as Jeff said there
Democrats are worried that these
scandals could spoil their chances of
retaking the legislature later this year
now after the top three scandalize
leaders comes the Republican House
Speaker he has said that the governor
should go but he hasn't said that the
lieutenant governor or Attorney General
should resign at least not yet
John ahead thank you and it's amazing
remembering in 1989 Douglas Wilder was
the first African American elected as a
governor to any state as an African
American in every state of Virginia as